sachez qu'aujourd'hui les équipes
d'abdul et camille sont allés dans la
rue et on a montré des photos de tous
les chroniqueurs de tp on a demandé aux
passants de vous donner un âge d'avoir
leurs avis sont très bons regardez ça
merde oui les beaux gosses quoi
cinquantaine facile et après tu es blanc
en moi qui se teignent les cheveux 32
ans benjamins je pense qu'ils auraient
plutôt 57 en quarantaine d'années avec
ou sans botox avec botox là sur cette
photo en tout cas un et je me connais
moi lui je dois atteindre les 60 ans
silouate 68 ans 45 ou 65 à dire ça les
rides les pattes d'oie s'écroule vu sa
calvitie et ses cheveux blancs plutôt 60
ans mais soixantaine d'années est marqué
j'ai eu l'occasion de voir de près je
travaille dans le quartier
non mais bon sans maquillage sûr que ça
change complètement où elle je dirais
plutôt qu'il est là
57 ans elle est très belle mais bien
marquer valérie 45 ans aussi la grèce
wall est pas très vieille halle et 30
mais saisit pas pour une dame à la connu
jacques martin doit être né en 45 75
verges
j'ai connu ça ait pas faire ça mais j'ai
eu à la tv fiction tc aouate 80 comment
s'appelle winger hanouna alors cyril
hanouna il va il a quand même il est
assez marquée quand même à et là
quelques rides 1 46 ans 45
physiquement il doit plaire à sa femme
s'il est déjà pas mal vu
franchement elle ça ça arrive c'est très
dur en guest maillet du bois sauvage
volonté tout temps